oh it's funny uh why nigga's crazy you
would comment it on uh kanye uh
getting his only fans porn off of reddit
right right
because a lot of people
will go on reddit and get
all the only fan [ __ ] or discord or
whatever for free i've heard
um i'm sure that that your shit's
probably on there somewhere i would
assume i've never seen anybody i've seen
it you have
my baby mama said is this adam where's
my lawyer there was him i need that [ __ ]
taken down i want to read it but no but
you had pretty much been like yeah like
that's real [ __ ] funny you know
taking advantage of you know i just
think like if you're a billionaire or
even a millionaire
and you're bragging about how you're
like not paying some girl like eight
dollars to like see her videos that you
apparently like looking at or whatever i
mean like i don't know to me that's just
corny as [ __ ] i'm not gonna like make it
this big [ __ ] stink i know a lot of
people are like accusing me of simping
whatever but i mean to me it's the same
thing as like you know you go to a
restaurant you spend 200 on dinner and
it's like
maybe the waitress didn't really [ __ ]
do [ __ ] but you're still gonna give her
40 bucks for the tip right yeah it's
like i mean
i just don't understand how somebody
would think it was like a cool thing to
brag about not paying for that when it's
you know he wants people to pay for his
music right i'm sure if there was like a
mass campaign and people bootlegging his
music he'd be upset right um i mean it's
fair isn't it the same it's close to
your heart yeah yeah well i mean i just
a lot of times it feels like people
don't want to stand up for the girls
this is true i stand up for the girls
porn lives matter with him porn lives
matter porn lives matter hmm you said it
first not me